TheraTears®.
>> Laura: IT TIME NOW FOR
HOURS SEEN UNSEEN SEGMENT FOR WE
FOCUS ON WHAT IS BEHIND THE
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
FIRST OFF, RYAN SEACREST UNDER
PRESSURE MORE THAN EVER FROM THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT.
LET'S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO, A
GANG UP ON MEN TIME, ALL THE MEN
ARE EVIL, ALL THE WOMEN HAVE THE
ANSWERS.
>> THIS MAKES NO SENSE.
THEY LOOKED INTO THESE
ALLEGATIONS, SPENT TWO MONTHS,
THEY CLEARED RYAN SEACREST, SAID
THERE WAS NO    NOT ENOUGH EVIDE
THERE WAS NO    NOT ENOUGH EVIDC
THERE WAS NO    NOT ENOUGH EVID,
THEY CLEARED HIM.
NOW WITH THE OSCARS COMING,
KNOWING THAT RYAN WILL BE A
FIXTURE, THE WOMAN MAKING THE
ALLEGATIONS, THE MAKEUP ARTIST,
HAS GONE PUBLIC WITH HER
ALLEGATIONS.
>> Laura: AFTER THEY HAVE
ALREADY BEEN INVESTIGATED.
HE BEGAN TO WIN IN THESE
SCENARIOS.
EVEN IF YOU'RE CLEARED, YOU END
UP GETTING TRASHED.
I'VE GOT TO READ THIS -- BELLAMY
YOUNG, THIS ACTRESS, COMES OUT
THIS WEEK, AND SHE CONTINUES TO
PILE ON.
>> LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK THIS IS A TIME TO
STEP ASIDE AND LET SOMEONE OF
EQUAL TALENT THAT IS BEYOND
REPROACH BE IN CHARGE.
NOW THAT SOMEONE IS ASKING, DO
YOU CONSENT, WE GET TO SAY NO,
PEOPLE HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT AND
STEP ASIDE.
>> Laura: BELLAMY WANTS
SOMEONE IN HOLLYWOOD WHO IS
"BEYOND REPROACH."
GIVE ME THAT LIST.
>> #MeToo IS GREAT, BUT
FAIRNESS HAS TO FOLLOW, AND YOU
CAN'T KEEP DREDGING UP
ALLEGATIONS.
>> Laura: OKAY, BABS, CLAIMING
THE ELECTION WAS RIGGED AGAINST
HILLARY.
THAT CADAVER, POLITICAL CADAVER,
BLAMING TRUMP FOR THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING?
YOU READERS.
>> HERE IS BARBRA STREISAND.
"I REALLY BELIEVE
HILLARY CLINTON WON THE
ELECTION.
SHE TALKED TO SENDERS FROM
MICHIGAN -- I TALKED TO SENATORS
FROM MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN.
I DO BELIEVE, LIKE I BELIEVED
DURING BUSH, THEY WERE PLAYING
WITH THESE VOTING MACHINES."
WE'LL LEAVE IT THERE.
>> Shannon: PLAYING WITH
"FUNNY GIRL."
>> WELL, I DON'T MEAN TO RAIN ON
BABS' PARADE, SHE CLAIMED TO
TALK TO SENATORS FROM WISCONSIN
AND MICHIGAN.
YOUR PRODUCER TODAY, ALL THOSE
SENATORS, GUESS WHAT, THE TWO
SENATORS FROM WISCONSIN SAID, WE
NEVER SPOKE TO BARBRA STREISAND,
WE NEVER SUGGESTED THERE WAS ANY
VOTING FRAUD IN OUR STATE'S.
THAT THERE IS, THEN THE FUNNY
GIRL NEEDS TO GET THE STATES TO
CALL THEIR ELECTION COMMISSIONER
AND LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THIS IS PEOPLE WHO
NEED PEOPLE TO MAKE THE CALL.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: ♪♪ PEOPLE ♪♪
MELANIA.
NOW WE HAVE THE CREW ON "MORNING
JOE" WHO ARE PERPETUALLY PILING
ON MELANIA AND IVANKA TRUMP, AND
THEY SAID TODAY SOMETHING
THAT -- I THINK WE JUST NEED TO
WATCH.
>> THE WHOLE THING CLEARLY IS A
JOKE, AND UTTER JOKE, JUST LIKE
MELANIA'S ROLE ON CYBER, YOU
KNOW, BULLYING, WHICH I THINK IS
AN INSULT TO WOMEN COMPLETELY,
AND EXPECTS JOHN KELLY TO BE
FORCED TO PUT IT IN A STATEMENT
ABOUT IVANKA.
THESE WOMEN HAVE BEEN GIVEN FAKE
JOBS.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW IF I
WERE MIKA, TALKING ABOUT FAKE
JOBS.
THAT SHOW IS GARDENING WITH THE
KIDS.
FAKE JOB, OKAY.
>> #MeToo SAYING THAT WOMEN
NEED TO BE RESPECTED --